Hello everybody. This is Dr. Cutters. I wanted to share a short video because I
will be doing the Zoom this week. The show will be there is multiple questions
that came in that I want to do a dress. So I put together a little slide
presentation on this that hopefully this will cover answers for everybody and
help other people that are may have these same questions. First of all, there was
somebody that had some diet questions on if I'm on a diet that's low in sugar
can I eat fruit? So the answer to that is yes and no. So there's there's a
benefit to certain fruit. Fruit has different nutrients, micro nutrients in it
that can be extremely beneficial to help fight cancer and and deal with
different things. Fruit can be gratifying, it satisfies a sweet tooth and such.
But there are certain fruits that have more carbs and there are certain fruits
that have fewer carbs. And as this chart points out, the ones on the left have fewer
carbs, the ones on the right have a greater number of carbs. So we're talking about
carbohydrates, carbohydrates are what break down to glucose. Glucose is what feeds
glycolysis and what can fuel cancer. So we don't want to be eating a lot of glucose
even if you're on a mixed diet where we're still trying to reduce glucose level. So
people on a ketogenic diet may not eat really any of these fruits except maybe coconuts on this list
in some lemons but they would probably stay away from even melons as well on a ketogenic diet
because all these are going to break down fairly rapidly into glucose ultimately.
Coconut nut so rapidly some of the like lemons and limes won't be very rapidly. There's not a lot
of fructose in there to break down to glucose. However, on a mixed diet, you still have to be
aware of any of these. We don't want to be just eating three or four bananas a day or even maybe
not even eating one banana a day and certainly not grapes and bananas and and a lot of fruit a day
because you are going to increase your glucose levels by doing that. So you want to use it
spheridly. So typically the more colorful berries are going to be better for cancer because of the
antioxidants and the different micro nutrients that are in raspberries and blueberries. Coconut oil
and coconuts are always good for you on any diet. But there was also a question about coconut oil
and Alzheimer's just so you know your brain is mainly made up of fats. Coconut oil is a good fat
for your brain. There was a study that I've cited several times. I don't remember the date of the
study but it was a few years ago now they were they did what's called an MMI in Victoria which is a
a assessment test for dementia and early dementia. I can't remember. I think there was 31 patients
that were assessed to have early dementia and none of them were medicated. All they did with all of
those patients is put them on three table spoons of coconut oil per day. So they consumed three
table spoons of coconut oil a day and after one month they reassessed them with that with that test
and every single one of them improved their score on a test. That was the only change that they made.
So coconut oil fats are very very very important for your brain so consuming fats is a really important
thing that you want to continue to do and coconut oil is a good source of a paired oil fat for you.
As far as you're on a low sugar diet again just try to abide by some reasonableness.
We don't want to be spiking our glucose levels and certainly you can go out and buy a
glucometer and measure your glucose to try to keep your glucose levels down. You're fasting
upon rising when you wake on a bed glucose should be below 90 that's what our goal is.
So if it's not below 90 then we know we have some work to do with our diet. Now typically most
my patients are not going to be below the idea of fasting glucose but they first come here.
And as we start changing their diet and clean out their diet then that will start to drop.